une centaine de lycéens grévistes s'est
massée devant le lycée parriat de
montceau-les-mines ce matin sans pour
autant bloquer les portes de
l'établissement
certains arboraient un gilet jaune en
signe de soutien à ce mouvement
mais ce n'est évidemment pas la hausse
du prix du carburant qui est leur
principale préoccupation
les moyens alloués au lycée et leur
avenir en tant que futurs étudiants les
inquiètent bien plus mettre 40 environ
dans une classe et c'est pas possible
j'ai dit non a appris qu'elle va à 30
personnes dans des classes est pas
possible d'apprendre c'est pas possible
les gens qui sont en situation précaire
économiquement parlant ne peuvent plus
réellement aller en université car ça
devient de plus en plus compliqué est de
plus en plus cher avallon même
mobilisation devant le lycée des chaumes
ici c'est la réforme du lycée et du bac
avec l'introduction d'une bonne dose de
contrôle continu ainsi que parcours sup
qui agite les esprits
ça veut dire que notre dossier il doit
être parfait de du premier jour de la
rentrée scolaire jusqu'au bac
ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas le droit à
l'erreur ça veut dire du stress en plus
on n'y a pas de répit à dijon des jeunes
se sont également mobilisées au lycée
eiffel
et puis forte mobilisation également ce
matin à nevers plusieurs centaines de
lycéens ont formé une chaîne humaine ils
ont été mobilisés sur les mêmes
revendications